con vote for animals noi chiediamo anche un cambiamento
radicale sul trasporto di animali vivi.
la commissione europea infatti
si è impegnata a
proporre una revisione della normativa che regola
il trasporto di animali vivi per scopi
alimentari, come il trasporto via
nave o il trasporto su lunga distanza.
ma purtroppo la proposta della
commissione presenta ancora troppe lacune.
ad esempio il trasporto di animali vivi via
nave verso paesi extra europei è ancora concesso
ed è un traffico che, eh, ormai si SA,
ha causato decine di migliaia di morti di animali.
spesso sono trasportati in condizioni veramente
inaccettabili,
per cui chiediamo che questo trasporto venga vietato.
un altro esempio sono i trasporti su lunga distanza
come quelli di agnelli che abbiamo documentato in
tantissime indagini dall'est Europa fino all'italia.
noi crediamo che i partiti
candidati e candidate
possano fare molto nel nuovo Parlamento europeo,
per questo su vote for animals punto i.
t. chiediamo a tutti di informarsi
e aderire alla nostra campagna
per vietare per sempre queste pratiche
crudele e ingiuste.